it comes down to like your safety as
well yeah of course but that's I think
it's a bit different in that situation I
gotta say when when you're seeing it
happen yeah there's that as well the
Judgment call comes in a little
different to what like in reality about
what we might plus it's actually for
this man to protect I think like the
first thing
yeah that's why I think girls get away
with a lot of stuff too is they know
that they know if they they act a
certain way in public men will come to
their rescue because yeah you should
have been caught crying and stuff
because like our default is like oh
protected she's crying she's hurt you
know how many times go doing something
to a guy and then her boyfriend having
to Bear the repercussions of her doing
that thing today yeah so you know a
woman starting on the man and then that
man punching her boyfriend up can I I
think that's starting to reverse though
now I I've experienced it personally
um I used to open the door for every
woman young or old and so many times
have I had to say thank you for them
and I'll say it loud oh you're welcome
you know and and what I'm walking away
thinking is like you know what that's
the last time I ever opened a door for a
woman seriously and and I've I I'm
ashamed to say that I saw it because it
changed me in the negative I think
that's something I should do for
everyone I was taught that that's what
you do for a woman I believe that's
wrong I think that's something you do
for everyone but I see that the chivalry
that a lot of women like to see in guys
is kind of disappearing
I think we're in a state where one group
of us wants it the other group of us
wants to do it but doesn't see the point
and actually gets a lot of crap you know
what I've noticed so we're just kind of
like at this point we're like you know
I'd rather just you do you even if
you're in the corner and you're getting
hurt I'm going to go over here because
I'm not interested in the consequences
of that you know what I've noticed is
that when women say they're romantic
they mean they want the man to be
romantic romantic it's not themselves
like they would never buy flowers they
want the guy to buy flowers for them
that's what romance is to them can I ask
something that's true interesting that's
very that's Luke at least of modern
women it's maybe the older Generations
women used to do things for their guys
in other ways but I think yeah because
then men with a price though exactly oh
I have a question for the girls what's
the most romantic thing you've done for
a guy
good one
um so I've done like
um a rooftop sort of picnic thing
um for my well then he was my boyfriend
so
um went shopping got all the food he
liked and just had that romantic setting
for him and he really appreciated it do
you think that's something that you
would have wanted or something he would
have wanted
a nice one
um
is that something you would want to know
he would have wanted
or did he just appreciate it I think I
think he really liked it he even called
family in Zoom call when he was like
look what she did
I guess what he's saying did you do for
him what you wanted him to do for you or
did you actually think like this is what
that man wants yeah do you think that
men walk around thinking oh you know
what I really want a romantic rooftop
thing yeah because I would love that I
would love that but I know what you're
talking about we would probably like to
watch Die Hard by ourselves romantic for
us
before you carry on what you did was
wonderful no no it was yeah we don't
want to take away from what you've done
we're just trying to Yeah Yeah
from the perspective of a man like if I
for example I I just came back from
Scotland I had a beautiful visit with a
woman that I adore she's if I was to
marry a woman this would be exactly the
type and she's old school she takes care
of her man and one of the things that
she did for me when I arrived
is she she had a suit waiting for me and
she put that suit on me she made me
dinner that night
we went out we went to the Jazz Club
over in Scotland I went up on stage she
sat there and chilled and waited for me
and when I was done and everybody was
done talking to me she just sat there
and she waited for me
that was what women would consider
romantic from a guy's perspective I
don't think that's really romantic from
a woman's perspective but if you want my
heart
that's that's how you get it because she
did everything that I just wish every
woman would do for me I see your point I
think maybe if the question was asked to
my fiancee maybe he might come up with a
different example of something else I've
done but because the question was not
because to me I would say that's
probably the most romantic thing so I'm
gonna frame it I can't frame it as a man
I would love if someone did that for me
oh my God but General men are romantic
for themselves I mean it's different
what about you Jess my mind's just blown
right now because
um what I did I would say probably one
of the
most romantic things was similar to
yubo's for his birthday I like balloons
happy birthday and it was a surprise
didn't know that was happening God was
some of his favorite stuff
um bought some things that he needed and
just like a little goodie bag and then I
surprised him confetti everything
balloons the whole nine and from hearing
what you guys are saying that's
something that I would want someone to
do for me like they're probably like hey
babe like your birthday this Saturday
and I'm like no no it's not like that
but what
like to understand like how men think
what is like something that is to say
for your birthday what is something that
you would want a woman to do for you
that is romantic and a man sent and
Manson not in the woman's for me
personally for me personally all I need
for my goal is to you know
put on some animes on our watch and
order some pizza and we watch it
together and I'll become that's that's
what I do like I wouldn't need much more
than that buy me PS5 if you want what
would be what would be above and beyond
so buying you a PS5 you're buying buying
a PS5 taking me abroad like anything
like that oh you wanna be you want to be
taken out here
where you want her to take you like man
there could be some girls in the chat
watching I'm a married man
without a ring look at look at fly him
out
what I would say it is it's like it's
the little things you know if you're
showing interest in the things that I
have interest in then that's that's all
I'd need like I wouldn't need anything
extra to me the best thing is like where
they listen to you say you said
something at some point oh I really want
to read this book whatever because
that's what my ex did she was in Sweden
I was in Australia I told her once ages
ago I really want to read this book
sapience I don't know if you read a
great book I wake up one day I have a
delivery it's that book why should you
explain
once you know that because when I was
when I was with my ex-boyfriend I bought
him like a phone wallet once and it was
just because he like mentioned he like
needed it but it was I didn't understand
why I was such a big he was like that
was so nice and I was like it's just a
while it was like five bucks I just saw
it at the store
yeah interests right women like the
gesture you know they like to go window
shopping because they like the ACT men
purchase things because of a need that
needs to be satisfied that's when we go
shopping we go on a mission to be
accomplished as quickly as possible
women like to extend the time as much as
possible because it's the ACT okay maybe
I'll disagree this is just oh no for me
personally yes we were raised like boys
yes that's right I'm a boy